let's talk about the future okay from
New York NBC New York Hospital won't
deliver babies after unvaccinated staff
quit six maternity staff members
resigned from Lewis County General
Hospital during the past week worsening
an existing staff shortage so you've got
a labor shortage then they do the
mandates then more people quit now they
can't deliver babies so let's let's
let's head on with the point you're
making first this is what happens with
the mandates people are like I won't do
it I'm gone you want to talk about the
Future these babies where will they be
born they'll be born and they're going
to be born in different circumstances
this will have a profound impact on this
country for 40 70 years so I take a look
now we were talking about this the other
day about these like uh these young
Democratic Socialist types these gen
zeers who are like in their 20s and
their socialists and they don't care to
interact in good faith on Twitter you
know you'll they'll say something like
pronouns in the bio right that's is that
is that zuby's razor Ruby's razor yeah
well so I I've tried in good faith
interacting with people and they'll say
something inflammatory I'll respond with
a simple Point not inflammatory and then
they'll respond with derision and
insults and you know I think is that
these are the kids of the 2008 financial
crisis they were they were kids growing
up at a time when their parents were
hurting and then as they get older and
Millennials also a lot of them
you live in this nightmare dystopia of
financial crises and warped values
celebrities Ultra Rich for you know
photoshopping their faces on Instagram
what values do you hold and now they're
voting for people like Joe Biden why
because it's funny you know that
everything they said about Trump and
Trump supporters is them voting for Joe
Biden was was the right thing to do
because Trump was bad but they accused
Trump supporters of voting for Trump
because it was a troll or it was a game
what we have now is a generation of
people who don't care about the outcomes
don't have strong moral values
generally don't care other than you know
I don't know is it going to be funny am
I going to troll somebody is it going to
watch the am I going to watch the world
burn or whatever they call that
opportunity cost the cost that you of of
what you don't do because of what you
did like if you choose to do this all
these other things that you didn't do
have a cost because you could have made
money or made things from all those
things that you didn't do the
opportunity cost of the war in Iraq is
now we have psychotic people walking
around that think it's normal to be at
War we have the financial crisis kids
stressed out because their parents are
stressed out
imagine that growing up imagine growing
up with like a Leave it to Beaver family
you know you walk in and there's a big
stack of pancakes and bacon and they're
like go to school and work hard son
you're like oh joy and your problems
were mostly like interpersonal issues
but not my family lost their house we're
struggling there's homeless people
everywhere now take a look at the kids
being born today yikes man fourth
turning right maybe hard times will make
strong men and then we'll get a boom
period in the next 20 years or maybe
you're gonna have a bunch of dejected
angry dystopian babies who just want to
watch the world burn man yeah a
generation of jokers yeah I think a big
problem as well and I I touch on this a
lot is I always say that in the modern
West there's something that a lot of
people lack and those two things are
perspective and gratitude
right because I was kind of having this
conversation with Lydia earlier which is
that
it simultaneously true that things are
going crazy and it's kind of scary and
this is getting worse and that's getting
worse and this is bad but when you kind
of zoom out on a historical level or on
a global level you're still like man we
live in we we live on some in some
Fantasy Island I mean just what we're
doing right here is magical any of our
ancestors would just see this they'll be
like what they'll be like wait how is my
how is my great great grandson earning a
living and making money he's doing what
he's talking uh wait what internet what
what are you doing microphone like the
whole thing on parchment and sending it
overseas by by boat yeah and there's so
much opportunity we all know we're all
online people we can see the sheer
amount of opportunity that's out there
as well is phenomenal like what I do for
a living what you do for a living even
just a couple decades ago even 15 years
ago it wouldn't have been able to be
possible in the way that it is now so we
live in this weird
there's this weird uh I don't know the
right word juxtaposition where
simultaneously it's like oh man like
this is really worrying there's this
moral Decay there's this cultural
malaise people are giving up their
freedoms people are wanting to embrace
radical ideas and cause this Division
and whatever but then on the flip side
you're also like man
compared to previous decades in previous
centuries things are amazing and you
look around the world and it's like oh
wow actually you know where would you
rather be you get all these people the
USA but I was like okay well where do
you want to move to who who is that
comedian who is cranking in front of all
those women he got in trouble for Louie
Louie that's right yeah I'm pretty sure
it's him he has this bit where he's like
why is everybody so pissed off
everything's amazing you've got this
thing in your phone it can show you
whatever you want and people are
complaining and you know what uh it was
a great bit and I think someone needed
to just tell him about the rat Utopia
experiment and behavioral sync are you
familiar with the rat Utopia experiment
I am reiterated for me simple is a
simple version is the this dude created
the space where he put I think he put in
like eight rats or whatever gave him
unlimited food and water and just that's
it they had a Utopia and then after a
few Generations they started fighting
each other killing each other yeah they
some they some stopped reproducing
altogether there was some I think it was
the I think eventually became the right
experiment some were called the
beautiful ones they would groom
themselves to Perfection and do nothing
else some became gay and so this was the
uh the concept he called behavioral sync
now the problem is this is really
fascinating we had a
Shane who's writing for our Mysteries
show and he does articles on the site
talked to Brett Weinstein about this and
Brett said that one of the problems with
laboratory mice is they don't inherit
information like wild mice and rats do
every every species inherit some kind of
Knowledge from their parent like I
mentioned mentioned earlier you know I
got these baby chickens that are
completely raised by humans and they
don't know to eat bugs but if the babies
are raised by the parent chicken the
parent shows them to eat bugs so they're
not getting access to that information
so it'll be interesting to see I think I
think we're experiencing some kind of
Behavioral sync where we've gotten to
the point where everything is so good
that we've just lost perspective yeah
there's no struggling we need resistance
resistance is a natural part of reality
where if a tree doesn't have wind
resistance it falls over and if we don't
have external resistance we the internal
starts to resist itself because we need
resistance that's why working out is so
good you need to force trauma on
yourself or it will be forced upon yeah
and and that's so interesting I mean you
have to
if you live in a country like the U.S UK
Canada and you know and you're just
decently well off you literally have to
go out of your way if if you want to be
strong and resilient both mentally and
physically you have to deliberately go
out of your way to create hardship right
like I'm really into weightlifting
powerlifting bodybuilding and stuff it's
like and sometimes I laugh at the
concept because I'm like I'm literally
artificially
doing stuff that previous generations or
ancestors like the concept of this would
be silly to them wasting energy yeah
yeah like and and you have to do that
because if you don't just your
day-to-day life is so sedentary and so
inactive that your body is going to go
to crap if you don't actually create
that intentional hardship
um and I think like I mean if again if
you think of human beings it's so recent
and it's only in a certain part of the
world so far where
you can even where you even have this
luxury right all of our ancestors just
just to survive right right like what do
we do if we get hungry right
you open a fridge or you walk across the
street or you Tap a button on your phone
whatever and something just comes and
feeds you can get all these exotic foods
from different parts of the world in the
past or even in other countries it's
like you're hungry okay you gotta you
gotta Farm you gotta pull out some
vegetables or you gotta go hunt an
animal Chase I'm sure you've probably
seen these documentaries where people
are like chasing one animal for like 12
hours or something and then they kill it
and I'm just like that's more close
actually to the human Norm than the way
that we live you ever see or you ever
read or see the Watchmen story Watchman
graphic novel or movie I saw the movie
so like Dr Manhattan can see through
time like he can he perceives time
differently from humans it's like
non-linear and then there's that that
point where uh at the end when he's
confronting the villain you know there
was a he was the villain was using
tachyons to obscure Dr Manhattan's
vision of the future and then he says
you know I want to thank you I've almost
lost the joy of not knowing or I forgot
the joy of not knowing and I'm like that
idea right there there used to be a time
where you'd grow up not even that long
ago 100 years maybe and you'd be like I
heard a I I heard about in this one
Island they have food it's made of
snails and you can and they take it and
they put it in oil and you're like whoa
I want to try that and so you Charter a
boat and it takes three months and you
arrive and everything's different and
every ever all the clothes are different
all the food's different in your life
Wow and they look at you and they're
like your clothes are different and
you're like wow and you can go from
Europe into like East Asia where
everything's different it's still kind
of like that except when you get off the
plane nowadays what do you see oh
McDonald's McDonald's Starbucks Gucci
Hard Rock Cafe yeah
homogenization is stripping away you
know what fine you want to do all that
then give me Interstellar travel so I
can go experience something new we got
video games and that's kind of part also
part of the problem is people are going
in to the mind and playing all these
games to create trauma and like uh exert
effort and things and I don't know man I
think a lot of that might be tweaking I
think that's also why you know this this
is I have no scientific
background on this particular idea but I
I have a kind of hypothesis which is
that there's a level of
let's say anxiety there's a level of
anxiety that typically is deployed just
in being able to survive being able to
to get food and fight against the
elements and fight against disease you
know potential physical violence all of
that which
if you are living in a hard place or in
a hard time naturally gets expended bit
by bit on a daily basis and I think that
part of the reason why you're seeing
rises in even mental health issues and
people saying I'm anxious I'm depressed
all of this stuff I think some of it
stems from this energy or this anxiety
building up and not being dissipated
anywhere I think it's also why minor
threats get so exaggerated right whether
you're talking about the words or
violence Brigade we need space spaces
and Trigger warnings and you know and if
you what happens if you misgender
somebody what do they say you got banned
for it you're you're right but what they
say you're denying my existence you're
trying to erase me right it becomes like
it's like whoa like that that's such a
such an extreme response to such a minor
minor transgression I mean look at how
we're responding to this particular
virus we know what the survival rates
are in different demographics okay but
the response if if you were looking at
this response you would think that you
would think that the death rate was like
twenty percent thirty percent for right
if that were it then you'd be like okay
this makes sense have you seen the polls
of what Democrats think that is they
think it's ridiculously high there's
some people who think that you know
there's a 50 chance you know you get you
get the Rona and you're getting
hospitalized no matter how old you are
you've got people running around saying
you know I'm terrified or you know I'm
not I don't think it's safe for kids to
go back to school all of that and I'm
like man statistically the flu is two to
four times more dangerous and deadly to
Children than this virus and nobody is
freaking out about the flu nobody did
freak out about the flu and it's
literally more dead well to be fair okay
the issue with coronavirus with kovid
was the the novel meaning that yeah with
the flu there's different levels of
immunity among different populations so
this is why the flu pandemic of 1918
didn't affect China as much because they
had previously been hit by a similar
strain so when it came back around more
deadly they had some degree of hurt
immunity yep with covid the fear is it's
going to rapidly mutate it's gonna it's
gonna infect everybody to varying
degrees might not be as dangerous for
kids but it could infect other people
because it's going to sweep across you
know hit more people so we we do see I
guess I guess it's fair point that in in
kids we don't see the level of risk
ultimately I think the problem is
whether or not you you go through the
data and you look at you know I think
the the death rate for covet is like
double what the flu is uh overall you
mean overall okay all right not for kids
um but but the flu is it's it's still
similar with older people other people
are substantially more susceptible to
the flu than younger people the the
issue ultimately is that we we learn to
live with the flu yeah we we look at the
CDC study that says there's 80 immunity
I think and we should accept that at
this point and be like okay so we got
something that's bad yeah it's worse
than the flu but we're not changing it
yeah right so how about we protect the
vulnerable like we've been saying for
over a year we you got the vaccine
available 80 of people have some level
of immunity CDC says and mostly based on
the vaccine it sounds like we did what
we could do yep and that's why I was
saying earlier maybe at this point
nothing is there is is actually what you
need to do thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time